[Musique]
votre silence après le tweet malheureux
du ministre des comptes publics vendredi
et des déclarations incongrues des ports
des du porte parole du gouvernement ce
matin mérite est une réponse de soutien
aux élus de la république et au
fonctionnement de notre démocratie
alors monsieur le premier ministre
quelles mesures allez vous prendre
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui pas demain pour nos
fantassins de la république que sont les
maires de france
quelles consignes allez vous donnez à
votre gouvernement afin qu'ils
respectent la république
gilles est vrai que au lieu de faire des
tweets il vaut mieux dire en face les
choses vous avez raison et c'est tout à
fait vrai d'ailleurs je n'ai pas voulu
je le dis aux sénateurs d'allier lire ça
aurait été tout à fait inconvenant et je
suis respectueux des institutions
monsieur le président du sénat et je
suis à la disposition de l'assemblée
parlementaire en tant que membre du
gouvernement
j'aurais pu aussi lire les très nombreux
tweets d'attac personnel auquel j'ai eu
droit non pas avant-hier mais depuis un
an ou un an et demi et je ne l'ait pas
fait parce que vous avez raison il faut
élever le débat sur le fond monsieur le
sénateur y at il un problème de
rémunération a notamment de fiscalité
depuis 2007 des élus des petites
communes et non pas des petits élus
comme j'ai pu le lire ici ou là
la réponse est oui est-ce que cet
amendement correspondait à l'exposé des
motifs que vous avez présenté
l'honnêteté nous pousse à dire que la
réponse est non est-ce que lors de la
seconde délibération si monsieur le
président permet de terminer ces
quelques secondes
est-ce que la seconde délibération que
le sénat va demander le gouvernement
sera favorable pour rétrécir comme l'a
demandé monsieur le premier ministre
l'incitation fiscale pour faire très
vite dès 1500 euros d'abattement jusqu'à
dix-huit mille euros
la réponse est oui pour les communes un
détail les plus réduites mais nous
paraissait pas raisonnable et avoué le
avec moi de conserver que les présidents
de régions et présente département les
maires de grandes villes dont j'ai été
bénéficient des mêmes avantages fiscaux
que les maires des communes les plus
petites je me falloir conclu
m
situation absolument invraisemblable des
gilets jaunes qui ont le mérite de tirer
un signal d'alarmé
certes ils le font à leur façon qui
n'est pas la nôtre
mais c'est sans doute un degré profonde
exaspération
mérite-t-il d'être soupçonné d'être
manipulés par l'ultra droite et mérite
est il plus grave encore de que l'on
puisse parler de peste brune c'est
méprisant pour des français qui jusqu'à
présent ne font que manifester est ce
qu'on peut se dire entre nous que
reconnaître la bonne foi d'un certain
nombre pardon reconnaître la bonne foi
de ceux qui ont mis un gilet jaune pour
manifester est possible dire qu'ils
expriment une colère une angoisse un
désaccord qui est parfaitement légitime
est possible le dire et l'assumé et en
même temps dire qu'à l'occasion à
l'occasion un certain nombre d'entre eux
pas tous et qu'on peut faire la
différence ont eu un comportement qui
relève à l'évidence de quelque chose qui
n'est pas l'expression simplement de la
colère ou de leurs angoisses mais qui
est bien
le franchissement d'une limite de
l'intimidation c'est arrivé à des
parlementaires de l'intimidation
physique de la menace physique c'est
arrivé à des collègues parlementaires ou
parfois à des destructions de biens
publics ou à des violences y compris à
l'égard des forces publiques le dire
monsieur le sénateur ce n'est pas faire
preuve de mépris ça n'est pas faire
preuve de condescendance c'est
simplement essayé de décrire une réalité
qui effectivement est complexe avec des
mots que je crois juste
[Musique]